the movie is set in 1951 Manchester
England where the headquarters of the
secret intelligence service or MI6
intercepts a message informing them that
a mathematician named Alan Turing has
been robbed at his residence reacting to
this news two detectives are sent to
Allen's place to investigate the
burglary however Allen assures them that
everything is fine which arouses
suspicion and detective Knox mind that
he may be hiding something the story
then cuts to a flashback in September
1939 in London when Germany declares war
against Britain this declaration leads
to the evacuation of 800 000 children
from their homes amidst this the young
Allen arrives at what appears to be
Bletchley radio manufacturing but is
actually MI6 headquarters there he meets
with Commander deniston from the Royal
Navy who recognizes Allen's Brilliance
due to his early publication of
scientific papers at the age of 23. the
commander inquires about his interest in
working for the government to which
Allen responds that he's not interested
additionally he admits that he doesn't
speak German and that he wants to join
just because he loves solving
mathematical puzzles this creates a huge
turn off for the commander since
knowledge of the German language is a
crucial requirement for the job given
the need to decode German Communications
hence deniston believes that Alan is not
qualified and asks him to leave however
Alan being an exceptional mathematician
Reveals His perspective on German codes
viewing them as puzzles deniston then
calls his secretary to escort him out
but just then Alan mentions Enigma
revealing that he knows about the top
secret program he's being considered for
it is then revealed that Enigma is a
highly Advanced encryption device used
by the Germans for their critical
Communications if the Allies can
decipher its code it would bring an end
to the war deniston believes that Enigma
is unbreakable but Alan requests to let
him give it a try before reaching a
definitive conclusion following this
deniston introduces Alan to the team of
five other cryptography experts Hugh
Alexander John karencross Peter Hilton
Keith Furman and Charles Richards
together they're assigned The crucial
task of decrypting enigma the team has a
genuine Enigma machine which they
managed to smuggle out of Berlin however
they are unaware of the specific
settings required to decode the
intercepted messages it turns out that
the Germans change these settings every
midnight and the code Breakers have only
18 hours a day to crack the code
starting from 6am when the first message
is intercepted otherwise they must
beginning now Hugh the chess champion
calculates that there are a staggering
159 million million million possible
combinations every day as Allen begins
his work he realizes that no matter how
much they try they can't complete
checking millions of settings in 18
hours if they go manually as a result he
contemplates creating a machine that can
swiftly decode Enigma on a daily basis
and starts designing blueprints for the
same meanwhile in the present detective
knock discovers that Allen's records are
classified which raises suspicions about
why a math professor would possess
classified documents in an attempt to
uncover the truth knock fabricates a
document using a typewriter allowing him
to access Allen's service records to his
astonishment the files turn out to be
empty knock reports this peculiar
finding to the superintendent suspecting
that Alan may be a Soviet spy returning
to 1939 Allen complains to Denison about
Hugh the leader of their team he says
that the guy is denying him the
necessary funding to build his machine
in response the commander instructs
Allen to follow his leaders directives
confident Allen proposes the idea of
dismissing the entire team and
allocating the funds towards his machine
instead he argues that he requires one
hundred thousand pounds for this purpose
and emphasizes that only a machine can
effectively combat another machine when
his request gets denied Allen sends a
letter to deniston's commanding officer
Winston Churchill via MI6 Chief Stuart
to everyone's surprise Winston appoints
Allen is the new leader and gives him
the necessary funds after this Allen
fires Keith and Charles criticizing
their linguistic skills and code
breaking abilities just imagine getting
your cumbers batched like that by Benny
now facing a shortage of Staff Alan
decides to recruit talented people for
the vacant positions for this he
publishes a challenging crossword puzzle
in the newspapers telling interested
candidates to submit their solutions by
mail through this process he gathers
several promising candidates and
conducts a second test among them Allen
then provides six minutes time for the
candidates to solve another difficult
puzzle which took eight minutes for Alan
himself to his astonishment a woman
named Joan completes it in just five
minutes and 34 seconds impressed by her
abilities Alan hires Joan and another
guy for the positions several months
later Alan eagerly awaits the arrival of
his machine parts in a secret Hut but he
grows concerned when Joan doesn't show
up as a result he visits her place and
tries to convince her parents that she's
very necessary at the radio Factory
which is an official cover for their
true purpose however her parents hold
reservations considering it improper for
her to work and reside among men in
order to convince them Alan pretends
that Joan will be working in the
clerical Department alongside other
women this finally convinces Jones
parents who ultimately allow her to join
the workforce amidst these events the
British civilians are facing severe
hunger and deprivation due to the
ongoing War every week the Germans
relentlessly attack big cities as the
British struggle to forecast their moves
Allen and his team are also experiencing
repeated failures requiring them to
restart the code cracking process from
scratch each day frustrated by The
Continuous setbacks Hugh reaches a
Breaking Point and vents his anger
towards Allen contemplating the
destruction of his machine thankfully
the other team members intervene and to
prevent any harm one morning Allen
arrives at his workplace only to find
some Military Officers searching his
desk when asked deniston explains that
there's a suspected spy within Bletchley
Park he shows Alan an intercepted
telegram destined for Moscow encrypted
with a key phrase the commander has his
doubts on Alan and warns him that he
will face treason charges if any
incriminating evidence is found this
saddens on as he knows that his team
members as well as the commander don't
like him for his cold and off attitude
what if they Benny my batch thanks
cumber boy later Joan becomes aware of
the incident and takes Alan to a nearby
restaurant to lift up his mood shortly
after Hugh John and Peter enter the same
restaurant and Joan greets them warmly
she later conveys to Alan that his
intelligence alone is not sufficient as
Enigma is very smart she emphasizes that
he needs the support of his team but
they won't assist him if they don't like
him taking this advice to Heart Allen
brings some apples for his team members
the next day and attempts to establish a
more friendly relationship with them he
even tries to inject humor by cracking a
joke listen I may have been a dick but
you're all a part of my batch
as time passes Allen's team members
begin to change their perception of him
and gradually start to support him
finally after much effort Allen
successfully completes his machine which
he names Christopher however when he
activates it they discover that it's not
quick enough to determine enigma's
encryption settings news of this failure
quickly reaches deniston who then pays a
visit to Allen's Hut deniston informs
Alan that is associate from the home
office is displeased with the
expenditure of 100 000 pounds on what
they perceive to be a useless machine
growing impatient deniston then
announces his decision to terminate
Alan's job however the other team
members step in and threaten to leave if
their leader is dismissed they express
their faith in Allen's machine and
request for more time as a result
deniston reluctantly grants them one
month to produce results warning that
failure will lead to their Collective
dismissal later that day as the group is
chilling in a bar Alan tells Hugh that
he is not a spy in response he reveals
that he already knew Ellen wasn't spy
because he recognized a simple Bible
quote used in an encrypted message a
code that Alan would never employ at
present his Sergeant informs detective
knock that he has uncovered information
about Alan being homosexual and his
involvement with a male Hustler who
later robbed Allen's house the sergeant
suggests that this is the secret Alan
was hiding from the police also implying
that he is not a spy despite this
Revelation the detective remains
suspicious and asks for Alan's arrest
for a private interrogation back in 1941
Joan comes to Allen and shares her
sudden decision to return home shocked
Alan asks for the reason to which she
explains that her parents want her to
get married Alan doesn't want her to
leave because he likes her company so he
devises a solution to her problem he
rolls an electrical wire into a
makeshift ring and proposes to her for
marriage please make me the happiest
[__] kamba on the market the scene
then shifts to the engagement party
while everyone is enjoying themselves
Alan confides in John admitting his
homeless sexuality here it is revealed
that being homosexual is illegal at that
time John advises Alan to keep the
secret hidden even from his fiancee he
emphasizes that they can't take any
risks and on top of that deniston is
looking for any excuse to put Alan away
from the very next day the team gets
back to their work but the machine
Christopher's pace is still slow to
crack the immense number of
possibilities after yet another
unsuccessful attempt The cryptographers
Gather at a pub where Joan's friend is
also present the latter casually
mentions that while working she heard a
German coder talking about his
girlfriend hearing this Alan has a
sudden realization he understands that
he can program Christopher to decode
words he already knows to exist in
specific messages Alan then rushes back
to the workplace followed by his
teammates he reveals that the German
encoders always begin their first
message with a standard unidentifiable
German script by decoding these initial
messages they can quickly decipher all
the messages encrypted with that day's
Enigma code motivated by this
breakthrough Allen Alters his machine
accordingly and tests it with a 6 AM
message to their surprise Christopher
halts within a matter of seconds they
hastily jot down the letters produced
and rushed to the Enigma machine
inputting the same letters finally they
successfully decode the message bringing
immense Joy to the team throughout the
night they diligently decode a multitude
of German messages upon compiling all of
the decrypted information Joan manages
to crack that a British Convoy is about
to be attacked within the next half hour
reacting swiftly Hugh attempts to
contact the commander but Alan prevents
him from doing so he even breaks the
telephone to stop the information from
leaking out expectedly this enrages you
and he punches Alan hard in the face
causing him to bleed oh you better
batched my combo deck despite this Alan
explains his actions pointing out that
if they suddenly relay the information
to their seniors and counter-attack the
enemies the Germans will learn that
Enigma has been compromised this
knowledge would prompt the Germans to
change their encryption Machinery
nullifying two years worth of efforts
therefore they cannot act on every
decoded message so they choose not to
rescue the Convoy sadly Peter's elder
brother serves on one of the ships in
the Convoy and he pleads with the team
to redirect at least one one ship but
Alan apologizes that he cannot do so the
following day Alan and Joan board a
train to London to meet the MI6 Chief
Stewart meeting him in a coffee shop
they disclosed their successful cracking
of enigma however they request Stewart
to keep it confidential and instead
decide to act on only the bigger attacks
to save more people Allen asks Stewart
to find other sources to relay the
information to the Germans so that the
enemies don't get suspicious that the
Enigma has been cracked He suggests they
spread rumors that a British spy is
among the Nazis and that he's the one
disclosing all the valuable information
days pass and the team of cryptographers
persist in their efforts to decode
intercepted messages one day Alan
notices John's Bible and recalls Hugh's
mention of a Soviet spy using a Bible
quote this leads him to realize that
John is the Spy but before Alan can
report this to deniston John stops and
blackmails him saying that he will
expose his homosexuality to the public I
may be a traitor to the whole country
but you're super gay Bud later Alan
decides to come contact Stuart but soon
realizes that his calls may be
intercepted stressed he heads to Jones
apartment only to find Stewart there
Allen inquires about Jon's whereabouts
to which Steward informs him that she's
detained in a military prison Under
Suspicion of being a Soviet spy Alan
contradicts this by revealing that it's
Jon who is the true spy not Joan Stewart
confesses that he was aware of Jon's
true identity even before his arrival at
Bletchley Park and that he purposely
placed him there to leak information
before departing he also reveals that he
lied about Jones imprisonment and that
she has actually gone to the market
Benny just got dick batched later that
day Allen meets Joan and admits that
he's homosexual hoping it'll be enough
to persuade her to leave Bletchley Park
for good but unexpectedly she remains
unfazed by this Revelation and insists
that they can still lead a happy life
together fearing for Jones Safety Allen
fabricates a lie claiming that he never
truly cared for her and had merely
exploited her for her cryptography
skills this devastates her but she still
decides stay then we see more footage
from World War II while in a voiceover
Alan reflects on The Daily decoding of
messages He suggests that the outcome of
the war wasn't determined by bombings
and battles but by a team of six
crossword enthusiasts in a small English
Village move over Band of Brothers Here
Comes the combo batch after two more
years the war finally ends and Stewart
instructs the cryptographers to destroy
all evidence related to their successful
cracking of enigma he also says that
they should never reunite or disclose
their achievements in the future in 1951
Alan who was in an interrogation room
with knock seems to have shared his
entire past stories with a detective
following this Alan asks NOC to play the
imitation game and answer whether he is
a machine or a human however NOK is
unable to provide an answer six months
later Allen is convicted of gross
indecency and instead of serving a
prison sentence he undergoes two years
of weekly hormonal therapy aimed at
suppressing his homosexual tendencies in
1953 Joan visits salon at his residence
it turns out that she is now married and
living a normal life witnessing Alan's
physical and mental deterioration she
tries to console him by acknowledging
that his work saved countless lives
after her departure Alan gazes longingly
at Christopher his beloved machine
before turning out the light the
epilogue reveals that a year after the
mandated hormonal therapy Allen
tragically committed the unthinkable in
1954. 59 years later in 2013 Queen
Elizabeth II finally granted Alan Turing
a posthumous Royal pardon recognizing
and honoring his contributions that
ultimately paved the way for the
development of modern computers
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching